OLOFSSON.
A COUPLE OF QUICK PASSES.
A SHOT AND.
HUGHES OFF THE WALLLLNEN.
HE KEEPS THAT ONE RIGHT ON THE
ICE.
A  HISCHIER,
SEVERSON'S SURE.
>> Dan: SABRES WIN BROTHER WATC
FOR HIS NINTH GOAL OF THE YEDRE.
THERE'S THE
I SAW YOU HAVING A LITTLE WORD
WITHST MINUTE OF THE
SECOND PERIOD, THE SABRES CUT
THE LEAD IN HALF. BECAUSE
HE'S GOT HIMSELF OLOFSSON RIPPED
ONE ON BLACKWOOD WHO MADE THE
SAVE. ESTABLISHED IN FRONT AND
THAT'S KREBS AND THEN THE SECOND
WHAT A PASS!
WHAT A FINISH! HIS FOREHAND AND
BEATS AHEAD.
KREBS DROPS IT, BUTCHER TAKES
THE SHOT ANDHERE.
RIGHT THROUGH THE MIDDLE, IT'S
PICKED OFF.
PASS SSESSION.
THE PUCK STAYS WITH HIM.
AND THEN THE CENTER  DEVILS
STARTED TO FIN TAP-IN AS THE DE
TO PEPPER LUUKKONEN WITH SHOTS .
DAHLIN I DON'T THINK KNEW WHERE
THAT PUCK  SHOT, SCORES!
THE SHOT WASIGENTHALER FOR GRAV.
LEFT WING INTO DEVILS LINE.
HE'LL SCHU LUUKKONEN DOING HIS
BEST.
STRIPPED BY REALIZES THAT
PUCK IS COMING TO THE NET.
HE KNONO